dude i was thinking before you came in
here and i was talking i was thinking
about potential
do you whenever you were growing up did
you feel like you had a lot of potential
neck or what
what does potential mean if i think
about that
what does it mean yeah just the ability
to do
more than what you're currently doing
kind of and
i i always thought i did um
yeah i was always really unsure of what
i was going to try but like i just felt
like when i compared myself to other
people i was just like
i'm better or i like i'm not better but
i would see people in positions where
they are i was like well i could do that
kind of at at least right because that's
a good point i could do that at least
right so i have potential to do that
maybe more than that
or something yeah or an advanced state
of that
yeah just been thinking i was thinking
about potential earlier
and just like where does like potential
come from or what is it you know
um well look it up will you mind looking
it up
potential let me think about it real
quick
uh yeah i guess the a bit you could
because people that's one thing that
people i mean i guess people can
recognize your potential
people say that a lot you know or you
know you'll hear that term
uh recognize your potential uh
what does it say brother having or
showing the capacity to become or
develop into something in the future
hmm yeah because i was thinking about
popcorn at the beginning of this and how
you doing
no think about that dude popcorn you
would never guess it's in there
you would never guess it dude if you
looked at it
if you looked at a corn
bro and you wrote down 200 things that
could be in there
none of them would be popcorn all the
things i wrote down would be smaller
than what's in that
right so that's kind of potential you
know
yeah man i guess that you know what's
funny i guess i see potential in people
i guess if you see if you if
it's really kind of cool if you can if
you do see if you see potential in
somebody that's kind of like a neat
way to look at people i think i'm i i
don't do it all the time for sure i
forget about it a lot
but looking for somebody's potential
um yeah i wonder if you have
i wonder if potential is something that
other people have to say oh i i feel
like you have potential
or if somebody tells you that it
definitely makes you feel good that's a
big compliment or that's a big thing
because it makes you feel
motivated that you can do more i think
a lot of potential is mindset and
you can get that mindset from like other
people reinforcing it but
telling you and then you're like oh i
can do this and so then you give an
attempt at it
but like if you don't i think that's why
like there's kind of like a malaise
in like poor neighborhoods or whatever
people don't think they have the
potential to escape
but when someone from their area ends up
succeeding there they see
oh that's possible for me too and it
opens up a world of possibilities
yeah yeah that potential
when you see somebody doing something
and it makes you feel like oh i can do
that i could be that guy
yeah it almost ignites a part of you
that's um
i wonder if in the future there'll be a
medicine that or something that
that makes your potential kind of flare
up you know or just remind you that you
have it
i guess i need to just remember that
just trying to notice people's potential
more
um yeah i don't think i do a good job of
that sometimes i think i could probably
do better because i think
if you let people know man you have a
lot of potential you know i really see
this potential and even call out things
they do
that that really makes people feel good
huh yeah you know when people do that i
i've noticed just in my own life when
people say that
especially like if an older person says
that to you when you're younger and
stuff man you have someone you have so
much potential
you know i really see so much potential
in you uh
anyway yeah i was just thinking about
popcorn earlier
do you think i recognize your potential
nick or not yeah be honest man
i think so i mean i think just in the
position you gave me i mean there's
you need the potential to be able to do
do it so yeah
i think so and we talk about future
plans and
some of the stuff we can accomplish so
yeah that gives me encouragement that
you see it into me
yeah cool man
yeah but yeah tell me more how much
potential
come on uh let me think man
i think um i think you
i think you definitely exceeded my
expectations
oh thank you thank you and i don't mean
that in a bad way or anything
you know uh
but yeah i mean i think there's times
yeah you definitely
exceed my expectations when i know when
i'm in a place of like
feeling grateful i usually i'll often
think man i'm grateful for nick you know
oh thanks man so the hard part for me
sometimes is just
getting in that place of gratitude
generally
um but i think when you tell someone
uh that they do have potential too
there's part of them like
you on the receiving end of it you want
to live up to that so it like makes you
work harder
right like you're like oh he's i better
i better live up to those expectations
or or
thoughts he has so you work harder so
yeah um
just in general telling that to people
can help
yeah yeah yeah i could see that
yeah i can see that's probably how like
why some teachers are good and stuff
like that
because when they make a student feel
that way i think sometimes you just
don't know
like what's
you know sometimes you but sometimes a
teacher can say that a million times you
can say it for years and none of them
ever kind of cracked the surface it just
doesn't land
and then every now and then you'll it's
just it's almost like it has to be a
certain match up to between two people
and time you know when it when it really
when you're willing to hear it as well
and it really lands on you and you get
inspired
um i think also uh
one thing we've done and i think it's
like each other pushing each other this
podcast keeps evolving
in a number of ways because we're always
it doesn't have to be the same week to
week and i think that's
that's part of it yeah no well that's i
mean that's good to hear because i know
yeah it's like um yeah i think sometimes
i i want to like
try things different i get like a little
bit afraid i guess um
but yeah i think yeah there is some
evolution you know we've moved to some
different studios
um you know we've taken
you know it's a lot of times we're all
just take your suggestion i feel like
do you ever feel like you can't make
suggestions and stuff never that's
that's
an awesome thing about working in this
environment yeah we can
say whatever they sometimes are used
sometimes they're not but i mean with
this
whole studio like our layout and stuff
we we went back and forth and it became
it's a mishmash of both our our kind of
visions for it
yeah yeah that's true huh it's taking a
little bit longer than i thought uh it
was it's been a learning process for me
just kind of a project management like
because like
basically what's holding us up now we've
got construction people ready to go put
putting cords but i'm trying to talk to
engineers who are taking longer than i
thought
and and in the future that stuff before
we even got the contractor in here i
would have had
everything finished and that's like
what's holding stuff at the moment but i
mean we're still functional
but i want to be like plug and play yeah
and it would make my job easier because
we're
moving stuff back and forth for the
guest episodes the solo episodes and
stuff and eventually it'll get a lot
easier
no that's good to hear man yeah i think
uh
yeah it's um yeah it's been crazy in
here man it's been definitely been
unique
i mean it's just coming along it's just
uh and you've done a lot of it man thank
you very much
no problem evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one